so human computation the idea is that
there are problems the computers cannot
yet solve it's funny because there's
some of these some of these problems are
very simple problems seemingly for
example computer cannot tell you what's
inside an image they can tell you some
things but it can't really quite tell
you there's a cat next to a dog and
they're both running computer can't do
that
about humans we can do it super easily
and there are many things that computers
cannot do that humans can conversely
there are also things that computers can
do that humans can't do I mean computers
can multiply humongous numbers humans
may be able to do it very slowly and
we're error-prone and so the idea with
human computation is to combine both
humans and computers together in a very
large scale to solve problems that
neither can solve alone my project that
has been used by most people is a
project called reCAPTCHA where the idea
with reCAPTCHA is that um we take a
problem that neither humans nor
computers can solve by themselves which
is fully digitizing books the idea there
is we would like to digitize books and
the way this process works is you start
with a book and then you scan it the
next step in the process is that the
computer needs to be able to decipher
all of the words in this picture it's a
picture of words the computer needs to
be able to decipher all of those words
the problem is that sometimes the
computer cannot decipher these words
because for older books the ink has
faded a little and or the pages have
turned yellow so the computer cannot
decipher all of the words but humans can
so what we're doing with reCAPTCHA if
you are seeing these distorted letters
that you have to type all over the
internet for example when you buy
tickets on Ticketmaster or whenever you
get a Facebook account or something you
have to you have to type these distorted
characters that thing is called a
CAPTCHA and I was one of the people who
helped invent it and that thing the
reason is there there's a primary
purpose which is to make sure that
you're a human another computer and it's
because humans can read these squiggly
characters but computers can't this is a
security mechanism and it has been there
for a while but at some point I realized
the second use which is helping to
digitize books the idea is that some of
these words nowadays some of these words
are words that are actually coming from
books that the computer could not
recognize and
process and we're using what people
enter to help us digitize the books so
that's the idea and so this is a project
where it's it's about 1.1 billion people
in the world have helped us digitize at
least one word out of a book using this
so here we're taking some you know a
very large number of humans to do the
precisely the step that computers cannot
do in the book digitization process this
this is a company that was bought by
Google and by now Google is digitizing
the equivalent of about 2 million books
a year with basically humans typing
every now and then some of the words
through CAPTCHAs all over the internet
so that's that's the idea of human
computation